et ce qui est terrible c'est que vous
êtes entré dans ce couloir de la mort si
jeune que vous n'avez pas de souvenirs
vous dites on ne crée pas de souvenirs
dans le couloir de la mort évidemment
vous êtes resté 20 ans sans voir un
coucher de soleil
il nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20h ce soir Damien ecos bonsoir
Damien ecole
condamné à mort à tort en 1994 pour un
crime sataniste vous avez passé 18 ans
dans le couloir de la mort avant d'être
libéré aujourd'hui ce cauchemar vous le
racontez dans un livre intitulé La vie
après la mort publié chez ring et à 20h
dans Salut les Terriens
[Musique]
Damien ecole rebond soit vous êtes né le
11 décembre 1974 à westmenfis dans
l'Arkansas aux États-Unis alors votre
père faisait des petits boulots mal
payés votre mère ne travaille pas et
vous êtes à l'âge de 2 ans obligé de
partir vivre chez votre grand-mère dans
un mobil-home et à ça
mon père avait 16 ans
c'était encore à peine des enfants en
fait ils étaient incapable de s'occuper
d'un enfant alors la pauvreté finit par
faire exploser votre famille votre père
par vivre dans un hôtel mais pour
entretenir de bonnes relations avec ses
enfants il vous montre des films
d'horreur
aujourd'hui les films d'horreur c'est un
petit peu comme un nounours pour moi ça
me fait pas du tout peur les premiers
films qui m'ont montré c'est massacre à
la tronche je devais avoir 5 ans et bien
un jour vous voyez débarquer dans votre
vie un dénommé Jack ecole qui va vous
adopter à la demande de votre mère vous
dites c'est un [ __ ] haineux dont le
jeu favori était de me torturer en me
pinçant de me retourner les doigts et de
me tordre les chevilles
c'est tout à fait ça
nous a quitté quand j'avais 7 ans donc
elle s'est remarié et voilà un homme qui
a toujours eu du ressentiment pour moi
parce qu'à ses yeux j'étais le symbole
de sa relation précédente alors au
collège vous êtes de plus en plus seul
vous êtes pauvres vous êtes mal dans
votre peau et c'est là que vous devenez
gothique et question musique vous
écoutez Metallica entraxe Iron Maiden et
c'est à cette époque que vous rencontrez
vos deux potes Jason et Jay-Z alors
Jason devient votre meilleur ami Jay-Z
c'est un peu un retardé mental
QI entre 68 et 70 alors à l'époque dans
votre chambre les esquisses de Goya
remplacent les posters de skate et vous
vous enfoncez dans le dans le Dark et là
le 6 mai 1993 les cordes trois petits
garçons de 8 ans sont retrouvés dans un
bois l'un d'entre eux est castré on
parle de crimes sataniste vous et vos
deux copains vous êtes arrêtés pour ce
triple meurtre au procès Jessie le
retardé mental vous accuse vous et
Jayson du crime avant de s'accuser lui
aussi
lorsque la police est allée le chercher
pendant 12 ou 14h ils l'ont torturé pour
avoir ses aveux et puis évidemment il a
dit que Jesson et moi on était coupable
nous aussi
là tout est fait pour démontrer que vous
êtes un abominable sataniste on parle de
vos séjours en hôpital psychiatrique on
parle des esquisses de Goya dans votre
chambre de votre journal intime on parle
des livres de Stephen King que vous
adorez on parle de vos cassettes de
Metallica ce qui fait qu'à la sortie du
tribunal la foule veut vous lynchez
on a considéré que le procès n'était
qu'une formalité une formalité pour me
condamner à mort
et là vous vous retrouvez dans un
couloir de la mort vous allez y passer
18 ans
alors dès votre arrivée dans la prison
de haute sécurité de tuckermax vous êtes
amené dans un bâtiment crasseux infesté
par les rats et jeté dans une cellule
pendant 10 jours
ils m'ont torturé ils m'ont battu ils
m'ont affamé ils entraient dans ma
cellule à minuit ou une heure du matin
et il m'enchaînait au barreau et chacun
leur tour il me battait alors le
lendemain vous passez un coup de fil et
vous découvrez qu'en fait c'est 25
dollars les 15 minutes
la prison un contrat avec la compagnie
de téléphone donc il gagne pas mal
d'argent avec ses coups de fil là en
revenant de cet appel téléphonique en
vous revenez dans votre cellule vous
découvrez un paquet avec dedans du
papier un stylo des enveloppes timbres
un rasoir un gâteau au chocolat et c'est
un cadeau d'un dénommé DIU San qui est
en fait un bouddhiste et qui fait ce
cadeau finalement à tous les condamnés à
mort comme lui
c'est ça qui m'a mené vers le bouddhisme
et au fil des années que j'ai passé en
prison je suis entré dans l'ordre du
bouddhisme japonais c'est l'ordre dans
lequel on était formés les samouraïs
alors la cellule le lit c'est une dalle
de béton et la salle d'eau est délimitée
par une plaque en acier et le lavabo se
trouve là où devrait se trouver le le
bouton de la chasse d'eau ce qui veut
dire que pour se raser ou pour se laver
les dents il faut s'asseoir à
califourchon sur les toilettes des
Justen afterlin il vous donne juste
assez pour vous permettre de survivre
alors par la fenêtre la fenêtre en face
c'est une fente de 10 cm de large dans
le béton vous voyez un mur en béton
nuit à ma vue je n'ai pas vu la lumière
du jour pendant près de 10 ans donc ma
vue a beaucoup baissé alors la vie
quotidienne c'est 23 heures sur 24 dans
cette cellule une heure de promenade
avec les pieds et les points entravés
quand je suis sorti de prison
ça fait deux ans et demi que je suis
sorti il m'a fallu pas mal de temps pour
remarcher alors le petit déjeuner est
servi à deux heures et demie du matin
pourquoi parce qu'il y a des prisonniers
que vous appelez des esclaves qui
travaillent dans les champs donc tout le
monde même si on travaille pas dans les
champs tout le monde est obligé de se
lever à 2h30 du matin et comme les
lumières sont éteintes à 22h30
c'est-à-dire qu'on a que 4 heures par
jour de sommeil ininterrompu en fait
ils veulent que les gens travaillent le
plus possible parce que le système
pénitentiaire aux États-Unis repose sur
les bénéfices et puis il y a les rats
aussi et les insectes arrivent dans les
aliments et bien souvent ce que l'on a
dans l'assiette c'est un mangeable étant
donné qu'il y a tendance à sec
il y a les moustiques les murs sont
couverts de moustiques yes
on ne peut pas dormir parce que les
moustiques vous piquent vous piquent les
lèvres les paupières on les entend dans
les oreilles c'est intenable alors parmi
les condamnés à mort avec qui vous vivez
il y a des gens incroyables il y a Jonas
alors Jonas c'est un unijambiste qui est
prêt à tout pour une cigarette il est
prêt pour une cigarette à boire un
millilitre d'urine ou en s'enfoncer le
pied d'une chaise dans l'anus on a
l'impression que c'est une anecdote un
peu humoristique on n'y croit pas mais
ça existe et en fait terrifiant alors la
plupart des prisonniers sont inclus
qu'ils ont souvent été brutalisés dès
leur plus tendre enfance il ne supporte
pas d'être face à eux-mêmes dans cette
espèce d'isolement absolue et vous dites
ils deviennent méchants et bruyants
comme des babouins
d'une personne dans le couloir de la
mort aux États-Unis et de 85 donc c'est
pas les gens les plus intelligents du
monde et il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont
des problèmes mentaux mais il y a des
gens qui craquent tout le temps il y a
un autre prisonnier remarquable c'est
déjà ici alors lui il a le look un peu
d'Iggy Pop il a le corps recouvert de
grosses tâches noires et en fait vous
découvrirez que ces taches noires sont
des cigales qui la scotché sur ses
épaules sur sa poitrine sur son ventre
qui les appelle CBB et qu'il les
caressent pour les faire grézillet
et c'était une des choses les moins
bizarres qu'il faisait Jessie
alors il y a les gardiens les gardiens
ils sont extrêmement pervers et énormes
ils adorent les exécutions qui pimentent
leur vie quotidienne
ils font des espèces de petits font donc
à chaque fois qu'il y a une exécution il
boivent de la bière ils font une petite
fête il font la fête ils boivent un peu
vous allez rester là de longues années
en sachant que vous n'avez rien à y
faire puisque vous n'êtes pas coupable
du crime dont on vous accuse et ce qui
est terrible c'est que vous êtes entré
dans ce couloir de la mort si jeune que
vous n'avez pas de souvenirs vous dites
on ne crée pas de souvenirs dans le
couloir de la mort évidemment vous êtes
resté 20 ans sans voir un coucher de
soleil alors heureusement à l'extérieur
l'erreur judiciaire que vous incarnez
mobilise les gens vous recevez à ce
moment-là des dizaines de lettres et un
jour vous recevez celle de Lorie et là
alors que depuis des années vous êtes
scruté jour et nuit elle commence par
s'excuser de vous déranger dans votre
intimité
dès la première lettre que j'ai reçue de
Lorie je savais que c'était quelqu'un
hors du commun vous allez vivre avec
elle votre plus belle histoire d'amour
vous allez vous vous marier et elle va
vous sortir de là
travailler sur mon cas que tous les
enquêteurs et tous les avocats réunis
certaines fois on pouvait même pas payer
les honoraires des avocats et elle a
fait un emprunt bancaire pour pouvoir
les pouvoirs payer les frais d'avocat
pour moi et puis après Lorie les gens
qui vont s'occuper de vous c'est Johnny
Depp Tom Waits Iggy Pop Patti Smith
josman
et c'est ainsi qu'ils m'ont sauvé la vie
et puis le 19 août 2011 après 18 ans
dans le couloir de la mort vous
retrouvez votre liberté mais comment
vous avez fait pour supporter ça
je ne me projette pas trop à l'avenir on
met l'accent sur le présent sur ce que
l'on fait à l'instant donné si on sait
qu'on va passer 20 ans là dedans
évidemment c'est insupportable donc il
faut pas penser à ça il faut penser à ce
que l'on fait au moment où on y pense
alors voilà précisons qu'à ce jour le
crime dont vous avez été accusé avec
Jessie et Jason n'a pas été élucidé et
vous voulez faire une pétition pour que
l'enquête soit réouverte
je demande au président français
d'entrer en contact avec le gouvernement
américain avec le président Mama pour
que l'enquête soit relancée pour que le
coupable soit poursuivi pour que les
deux autres accusés et moi-même
puissions être innocenté merci de votre
témoignage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu